my house is littered with props from
films
is it really stealing if you take a prop
your character used for years
this dilemma didn't stop actors such as
daniel radcliffe and tom holland from
swiping some props from
set even when the studio has strict
policies in place
some actors break the rules to get their
desired items
here are the actors that just couldn't
help themselves from stealing some props
but i had permission so that's not
stealing rupert grint wasn't messing
around with what he took from the set of
harry potter
he attempted to steal the golden dragon
egg from the goblet of fire
which was worth thousands of dollars
however
the studio tracked him down and took it
back i only had it
in my possession for about 13 hours
grint was successful however in taking
the number four from the privet drive
house
so at least he got something cool what
the
bloody hell was that all about emma
watson wasn't shy
when it came to what she took from the
set of the harry potter films
the actress stated that she nabbed her
wand a cloak and the time turner we see
her use in the prisoner of azkaban
that's a pretty good haul and we'd say
she deserves it for all the time she
spent
playing hermione harry potter's round
glasses are a big part of his iconic
look
so daniel radcliffe made sure to keep a
couple pairs for himself
he has one pair from the first film the
sorcerer's stone
and one from the seventh film the
deathly hallows part one
radcliffe explained that the glasses
didn't actually have lenses in them
they are all lensless as well there was
rarely ever any glass in the actual
glasses because of filming problems with
reflections
radcliffe also has a prosthetic arm from
the second movie which
is a bit odd as he admitted himself what
a weird thing for someone to find in the
attic one day
i've got a prosthetic arm if there's one
person who would take a giant a
from a movie set and put it in his
office it's
robert downey jr remember the big a that
headlines avengers tower in age of
ultron
yeah that's what downey decided he
wanted
he asked marvel if he could take it and
to his surprise
they agreed and actually had it shipped
to him from england
to la that is one awesome memento
there was a massive avengers a which is
outside the uh
avengers center i have it
the late great alan rickman made sure to
keep a piece of his severus snape
character after he was done filming
he took snape's wand home with him and
according to lucious malfoy actor jason
isaacs
rickman also took a bunch of coins from
gringotts bank on the first day of
filming
one memento rickman was coy about
answering whether he had it or not
was his frock i don't think i dare tell
you the answer to that
there will be no foolish wand waving or
silly incantations in this class
kristen store revealed that she kept
several of the rings her character bella
swann
wore in twilight i kept the rings the
rings are really important to me
i i took the rings i took um
bella's moon ring stewart said it
reminds her of director catherine
hardwick
she also has the engagement ring her
character gets from edward
i'm gonna need that ring stewart's
twilight co-star took some items from
the set
as well although what he took wasn't as
glamorous as stewart's rings
pattinson opted for practicality
snatching a few pairs of edwards
underwear
he explained why in an interview they
have the best underwear
and i have no idea where they get it
from i use it every day
sounds like he made the right choice
this is what i am tom holland seems to
be a bit of a kleptomaniac when it comes
to taking props from film sets
this includes his spider-man web
shooters which he stated are quite
valuable
and tony stark's edith glasses from
spider-man far from home
apparently the one thing holland
couldn't get his hands on was his
spider-man suit given that
it's not the most inconspicuous thing
that's
kind of obvious 11 style transformation
scene in season 3 of stranger things
may have inspired millie bobby brown's
real-life style choices
brown admitted to stealing some of the
clothes from the store
although she noted that it was a set and
not a real store
but i did take um like corduroy jeans
and a stripy red and blue t-shirt
katniss everdeen can be seen sporting a
leather jacket and boots whenever she's
out in the woods hunting
the same can't be said for actress
jennifer lawrence
even though she has both the leather
jacket and the boots
she took these from the hunger games set
but never wears them
no they're just hanging in my closet i
don't know what i'm gonna do with them
we think she should rock the katniss
look
in her everyday life how'd we get here
huh
josh hutcherson also made sure to take
home a memento from the hunger games
films
he opted for the locket that peta gives
katniss in catching fire which includes
pictures of katniss's family
it's a pretty cool little prop and
hutcherson seems to be happy to have it
that's a good one it's my little
keepsake a lot of props were necessary
to create the 15th century set pieces
seen
in the king this included a lot of armor
and weaponry for the battle scenes
chalamet admitted that he took one of
the thick metal helmets
and a chain however he didn't get
everything he wanted
as he regrets not also grabbing his
sword i feel dumb because you're right
the sword should have been the thing i
grabbed but i grabbed the helmet instead
margot robbie appears to be a fan of the
birds of prey wardrobe as she took home
some articles of clothing after filming
i took a pair of shorts that
we didn't actually end up wearing as one
of the costumes that i really liked them
and i have one of journeys tops
zac efron is another actor who was keen
to taking home
some of his character's wardrobe he did
this on multiple occasions
putting together quite the collection he
has his troy bolton basketball jersey
from high school musical
his board shorts from baywatch and his
belt from hairspray
which he still wears occasionally there
is one thing he didn't get however
i don't have that wig anymore i wish i
did
chadwick boseman will always be
remembered for his amazing portrayal of
king t'challa in black panther
there were a lot of cool props from that
movie but much like
his character black panther bozeman
chose a prop that was low profile and
simple
the comoyo beats he can be seen wearing
them during a jimmy kimmel interview
and they blend in flawlessly with his
look the idea is to not be noticed
batman has a wide array of gadgets that
anyone would love to have
that's why affleck couldn't resist
taking one of batman's iconic batarangs
affleck isn't as sneaky as his batman
alter ego however and was caught in the
act
they asked for it back but affleck
refused because he thought he should be
allowed to have it
i thought i had a kind of movie star
pass for that kind of thing
the studio got the last laugh in the end
though as they sent him a bill for the
item
i kept getting these phone calls from
the prop department like
you sure you haven't found any of that
stuff yet ryan reynolds revealed that he
kept props from both his most famous
role
as well as his most infamous role from
green lantern
he kept the lantern's ring and from
deadpool he
actually kept the anti-heroes red and
black costume
he fell in love with the suit and said
he cried the first time he saw it so he
wasn't going to let
anyone stop him from taking it i was in
very good shape when i shot the deadpool
movie and i felt confident that i could
take out a 107 pound studio executive
because it was so emotional for me it
was the it was looked like it was ripped
right out of the pages in the comic book
the amazing spider-man movies gave us
one of the most gorgeous and detailed
spider-man costumes we have seen on
screen
so we don't blame andrew garfield from
swiping one of them from set
not only did he take the suit but he
also bragged about it
even though the studio was strict about
not letting the suits leave the set
but it sounds like he got away with it
in the end
dakota johnson appeared in her underwear
a lot
throughout 50 shades of grey and it
turns out she was a fan
of the undergarments i stole lots of
underwear they were comfortable
it's not the most glamorous item but
they are practical
hemsworth has played the mighty thor
multiple times and has
multiple meal near hammers to show for
it how many hammers do you have
uh about five he has so many that one of
them is just sitting in his bathroom
he also acquired a stormbreaker axe that
we see in infinity war and endgame
that's already quite the collection of
hammers and if he continues to play thor
we wonder how big his collection will
grow that means you have too many of
them i think
plenty bathrooms or too many houses too
many hammers like some others on this
list
chris evans opted for comfort when it
came to taking something from set
he said he took all his sweaters from
knives out but stated that he asked to
take them
because of course one of the nicest guys
in hollywood would ask permission before
taking anything
mostly clothes but i had permission so
that's not stealing
julie andrews portrayal of mary poppins
in the 1964
live-action movie is iconic and so is
her look
andrews wanted to take a part of that
look with her from set
so she nabbed mary poppins pink shoes
she doesn't still wear them though
and instead converted them into door
stops by filling them with sand
maybe not the choice we would have made
but mary poppins
does know best in every job that must be
done
there is an element of fun gandalf is a
mainstay character in the lord of the
rings
and hobbit films with ian mckellen
having portrayed the wise wizard in six
movies
mckellen took some souvenirs from set of
course pinching some gold coins from
smog's lair
along with the key to bilbo baggins
house he teased that peter jackson has
been having a difficult time finding
said key
which i know peter jackson is looking
for but will never find
when chris pratt was done filming
guardians of the galaxy
he nabbed star-lord's outfit did he take
it to keep as
a memento or to use as an awesome
halloween costume
nope he took it so he can wear it when
visiting children
in the hospital because he's an amazing
guy
he actually admitted to taking the
outfit before the movie even came out
if it was a big enough movie to wear kit
it would mean something to a kid who's
sick in hospital
as we know the movie did extremely well
and pratt kept his promise of visiting
children's hospitals as the character
liam cunningham wasn't shy when it came
to taking props from set
we think co-star maisie williams said it
best
he stole effing everything cunningham
said he went off with a u-haul truck
full of stuff this includes dothraki
swords
plural lumps of obsidian and bank of
braavos money
what did he do with all this stuff give
it to his kids so they can sell it in
the future of course
when i've blown all the money on horses
and fast cars and leave them with
nothing
they might be able to go on ebay and get
5 bucks for a coin
cunningham has it all figured out we
don't blame these actors for snagging
some cool props from their sets
who wouldn't want snape's wand or
katniss's outfit
we know we would which prop would you
like to have the most
let us know